these are all the the sound bites that i
wanted to go over
overall the book isn't as bad as i
thought it was
when i listened to the book summary it's
still pretty bad
and i would be asking some questions of
myself
and a check if you're getting involved
with them on a long-term basis
um you definitely want to make sure that
they're not going to complicate your
life
because the general underlying theme of
this book by the way guys
is um let's teach women to behave
like men um because we think men would
be attracted to that
and um go do that and that'll land you
the guy your dream basically is what the
book is for
it's it's written for women the
interesting thing when i was doing some
research say on it is i came across a
bunch of videos
on youtube where they were reviewing the
book
and it's your typical cast of you know
uh well into their uh
life you know 30s and 40s uh don't have
a guy in their life but they're praising
something
and they use a lot of terms like uh boss
girl or boss [ __ ] you know when
they're talking about it
um i didn't want to bore you guys with
playing all those clips because it's the
standard stuff that you've heard over
and over again but they get really
exciting
boss girl boss [ __ ] and we're the best
sort of thing so
there's a lot of that praising the book
overall again it's not as bad as i
thought it was
it's still pretty bad but there's some
key points here that i'm going to share
with you tonight
just to kind of um give you a little
more insight on
uh what this is all about because it's a
huge seller it's it's it's sell
it's been out since 2000 so 30 years now
uh she wrote a couple of follow-ups it's
been translated into a ton of different
languages from what i can see
uh it's been well reviewed around the
world and well-received in fact and
endorsed
uh by a female first primary social
order
so um it's out there you should be aware
of it i i remember
dating a girl uh around 2000
in the 2000s somewhere um that talked
about this book and had it on her
counter but i just dismissed it i was
like yeah whatever
uh it's a book for girls it's probably
like chick crack sort of thing so i just
kind of like whatever so
now i'm seeing why she was the way that
she was and why she was such a bee
but anyway um one of the main sound
bites i dropped at the top here was
men control the world but women control
men this is what the author um
put in the book somewhere in it i'm not
sure which chapter and what topic but
men don't control the world anymore in
fact uh women control the world and
women still control a lot of men
with the exception of guys that have
adopted the mindset of mental point of
origin putting themselves first
so they can go and chase excellence not
women um but again this is a narrative
that was
uh put out there in 2000 a lot of this
not a lot
a good chunk of it if i'm being honest
uh
echoes a lot of what the red pill says
so i made some notes here down at the
bottom
so i'll go through two of them real
quick before i start everything um
less is more which is essentially what
we call the soft next
it says here expressing your feelings
when you feel taken for granted never
works men are very skilled at tuning
women
out when they nag uh when you feel like
you've been taken for granted the best
thing to do is to back away if you want
to be respected in a relationship show
them that
show them what they could lose uh men
are used to dealing with emotional women
like their mothers or sisters
who forgive them even if they yell at
them for taking them for granted so this
is the
highlighted point here you have to let
him know that this won't be the case
with you
and give him the cold shoulder it's not
written as a soft next or
how we portray the soft next but it's
essentially
the same concept another one here is
a b moves to the rhythm of her own drum
and i just put in brackets of her mental
point of origin
when dating someone new it often can be
exciting fun to hang out with them but
having your own interests in life is
important that's why you need to make it
abundantly clear to them through your
actions not just words
actions right actions always trump words
right there in her book as well um
that you'll have life with goals and
ambition outside of dating them but
letting them know that you have goals
and ambitions that you're working on and
only have time to hang out with them
when you're free
makes your time appear more precious and
stops you from depending on them
to give you fulfillment and we all know
how quick
sorry and we all know a quick way to be
taken off a pedestal is to become
dependent on somebody else
for fulfillment i'll read that again and
we know a quick way to be taken off a
pedestal
so this so the underlying notion of this
book is
put yourself up on a pedestal basically
the title this book if a guy were to
read it
from his perspective would be why
plugged in men
love bees okay because plugged in men
believe
in putting women on a pedestal believe
on making themselves less
so she can become more that's that's the
plugged in mindset i've had it i know a
lot of you guys have had it
um and it's why a lot of these concepts
uh
are so powerful to men when they fully
understand them
you know rollo says that nothing is more
threatening and attractive to women than
a guy that knows his own worth right
so is to become dependent on somebody
else for fulfillment
this obviously does take a lot of
self-control and at the end of the day
you won't ever be putting yourself first
so this is
this is the concept of mental point of
origin so a lot of concepts that i've
talked about
in the past uh that i distilled in my
book are
actually in this book from 2000 by
sherry whatever her last name is uh
let's go to the first point here
uh why men love bees and it's broken
down by key
key ideas apparently the entire book is
broken down by key ideas so
uh why men love bees idea number three
men love the chase
so make them run um but to briefly put
nearly everything we've been taught
about men is a lie
for what sounds a lot like unplugging
doesn't it
for for what do they truly yearn well
strangely enough
they want us to make things difficult
for them
i don't know about you guys but if i'm
busy chasing excellence putting a dent
in the universe making bank
doing cool [ __ ] becoming more
significant all that sort of stuff
i don't want to deal with a woman that's
going to make my life
difficult you want a woman guys in
general now
when i'm addressing this i'm talking
about top shelf men
guys that i just described okay they
don't have time for women that make
things
difficult for them we want a woman to
make our life
basically we want you to make our life
easy and our d
hard that's it it's it's not that
complicated
not the other way around okay you make
our life hard
we're not going to be happy with that
plugged in guys might be okay with that
beta males might be okay with that but
at the end of the day
women don't pine for those men over a
long term basis
so in my view this key idea that's
mentioned here about men loving the
chase so make them run
and starting starting that point with
make things difficult for him
and then she goes on to explain how guys
love to chase and they'll go out hunting
with her buddies uncomfortable sleeping
arrangements bad weather
crappy food uh only to shoot a buck and
stick its head on the wall because they
like the chase blah blah blah
uh she closes with you you
can use this male tendency to your
advantage every time your partner wants
to meet you
even if you're free all week why not
pretend you're booked out
more free time for you he'll be kept on
his toes women who understand this have
a remarkably easy time in their
relationships
try it for yourself okay
yes guys don't want a woman tooth okay
let me rephrase that guys don't want a
chick on him all the time
no doubt about that but at the same time
we don't want
women to make our lives difficult we
want our lives to be easy we want you to
compliment our lives
not become the focus of it or make it
hard so there's a little bit of
conflicting information in there another
uh key idea from this book is
self-sufficient women will attract the
right partners
i'm all for it look you know go become
self-sufficient you want to climb the
corporate ladder put off child bearing
years
get promoted move from business to
business
do all that stuff if that makes you
happy get degrees you know print up the
pieces of paper frame it in mahogany
with little letters after name
and put it up on the wall there's
there's a there's a
really really funny thread called the
lawyers coloring book and i think i'll
cover it next monday because i got
andrew esquire joining me next monday
talking about dating professional women
um he's a lawyer
um and we're gonna talk about you know
dating women like lawyers and you know
the like around that so
i'll save that for next week i'll i'll
surprise you guys with that lawyer's
coloring book because it's really funny
but you'll get the idea but
self-sufficient women are fine
okay we don't want a a mooch
okay but at the same time she goes on to
close us with a story about how
a consider the story of a young
consultant working in manhattan she had
recently met a charming
handsome and high-flying lawyer who
after a few dates invited her to join
him on a luxurious
cruise she declined the reason
was she'd already been planning to host
a tupperware party that week and there
was no way she was postponing it
he was stunned and after just one day on
the cruise
he returned to new york to attend her
tupperware party
so high-flying lawyer invites her
into his life to join him on a
luxurious cruise she declines because of
a tupperware party
he goes on the cruise for one day leaves
it early
returns to new york to attend her
tupperware party
you can see where this is going by
putting her plans
first she surprised the lawyer and
showed him what kind of woman she was
a boss girl boss girl right
he couldn't help but fall for her and
was happy to spend an evening with her
and her girlfriends debating the best
way to freeze chicken soup
i can't even make this [ __ ] up okay
free like dude leaves a luxurious cruise
probably stacked with gorgeous women to
go to this
boss girls tupperware party and talk
about
freezing chicken soup and i talk about
the process of beta
through a thousand concessions in a few
different points in my book
this exemplifies it before they probably
even
had any kind of intimate interaction
together he's already beta ties in
himself by not putting himself
first i mean if she didn't want to come
on the cruise dude just invite just
invite another girl
or go to the cruise by yourself with
your boys there's going to be women on
the cruise
but leaving all of that behind to go and
enter her frame
while she you know denies entry to
your world it just doesn't make any
sense
and again you know this this key point
is an important one in the book
because she's encouraging women to
basically behave like men and you can't
have this [ __ ] on the sexual marketplace
you can't have
identities that are exactly the same
colliding with each other over and over
again
a man and woman need to be a compliment
to one another
and the way the book is structured is is
it structures women to basically behave
like bad men bad versions of men anyway
so there's that one
how are we doing for time 15 minutes and
good all right
uh white men love [ __ ] number five uh
keep
a relation keep a relationship fresh by
making your man wait
so in this one she goes on to talk about
um
you know there's a number of simple
strategies you can get out of fact
living your life in your own many hours
you dedicate your partner
reflect on it blah blah blah and she
closes at the end of it
making him wait will excite his
imagination the physical
intimacy you share will be all the more
special when the moment are right now
keep in mind this book was written 30
years ago
as a rule of thumb you can make your
partner wait at least
a month a freaking month
not in today's world maybe maybe
30 years maybe 50 60 years ago that
might have been
relatively normal today it's not you
make a dude wait a month today
he's got way more other options going on
especially you know he's a top shelf guy
but he's got way more other options
going on that he's going to entertain
and you're not going to be a priority
you're just going to become an option if
that at
all he might wait a month while he's
spinning some other plates while his
friends with benefits come over
if you're a unicorn or something closely
resembling a unicorn
but why i mean let's say you date
i don't know in you know the course of a
month you got four weeks maybe four to
eight times
i don't know you know depending on what
your schedule looks like guys today are
not
waiting four to eight dates for intimacy
women today don't even wait that long
you know
maybe a few dates so you know the
making him weight narrative i don't know
i mean
you can't have you know like one version
of
fem like toxic feminism and then go back
to like the 1950s like
you can't pick and choose from the a la
carte menu of
you know the sexual marketplace as a
woman that's inconsistent it's either
you're a traditional conservative or
you're not okay are you a traditional
conservative you came from an amish
village
and you're a virgin at 25 30 right and
you're making them wait for a month
because your plan is to get married and
have children all sort of
okay okay fine fine maybe we can have
that
conversation but you can't be a modern
woman
climbing the corporate day ladder you
know with your big ass
your big ass notch count right in the
carousel in your 20s partying it up
you know going from due to dude and then
all of a sudden you're going to make
this guy wait a month
too many conflicting pieces in this
right there's got to be more consistency
either teach the trad con
lesson or let's align things with the
modern sexual marketplace
this is too much of both number seven uh
let your man feel like he's calling the
shots okay this one's interesting
um i'm gonna catch up with your super
chats in a minute guys just
stand by give me a bit here um number
seven
says let your man feel like he's calling
the shots you can still run things
behind the scenes
so this is a highly manipulative tactic
okay um let's look at the story of an la
couple for guidance both husband and
wife were working full-time jobs
but she did nothing nearly all of the
household chores
he only helped out occasionally okay how
much money did he make versus how much
money did she make how many hours did he
work versus how many hours did she work
because generally speaking men travel
more meaning they commute more to go to
work they work longer hours
and they generally earn more so we're
leaving something out of the picture
here but anyway she's
she's the victim she's doing all the
household chores
he only helped out occasionally of
course the woman was irritated
she had better things to do than the
laundry but instead of getting critical
she praised him whenever he offered a
helping hand she expressed how happy she
was
that even after a draining day at work
he still did his part slowly her husband
began to do more chores until the
workload was balanced these days she
never even had to ask him to help out
that's because her husband began stress
so chore play
if you don't know what that is read my
book uh that's because her husband began
striving to
live up to his wife's expectations of
him just goes to show you how effective
praise is now
the bolded part here is what i want to
hit on you can also use the nudging
approach when facing big decisions
the trick here is to make him feel like
the idea was
his in the first place he'll feel like
he'll
he's in control while you're calling the
shots behind the scenes
you can do this by outlining three
options you're happy with
such as a summer vacation such as summer
vacation destinations
hey honey let's go to spain france or
italy
she's happy with any of those but she's
letting him decide
tell him how you love how he always
makes great choices
he'll feel great so will you the goal of
any good relationship
[ __ ] okay she's not going to feel
great about that because
she's basically running the show women
don't want to
lead they want to be led they want to be
with a giant that can make
shot call shots and make decisions and
she'll happily total line with those
things
if she's in his frame but this book is
talking about the notion of
essentially manipulating him into
becoming a better beta
i mean a lot of the notions in the book
are really about make him a better beta
like building the better beta build a
better beta book is really what it
should be subtitled or translated into
anyway anyway guys we're almost done
here um i'm going to grab
the uh invite link
and if you want to hop on the show and
and
ask a question live you can click this
link make sure you have a good internet
connection
and have headphones in just so the audio
is good
they usually have microphones somewhere
in them so there's a link guys
and in the private chat when you come in
the green room area
just let me know what it is you want to
talk about so i can sort through them
and prioritize them
uh and here's a few other short sound
bites men don't respond to words what
they respond to
is no contact ties into the soft next
success in love isn't about looks it's
about
attitude um if you're a woman it's about
looks
men women are beauty objects to men
men are success objects to women
you can take your attitude and stuff it
because
any top shelf guy is not going to take
any attitude
from any boss girl crap it's about looks
maintain looks maintain the aesthetics
of beauty
uh fertility health cues all that stuff
is what matters
you can take your attitude and stuff it
top shelf guys notice
that the only guys that women are going
to get using
attitude are going to be basically guys
that aren't going to turn her on over
the long term basis
um he might be you know good enough
might have you know genetic potential
for
you know genes you know for dad sort of
thing but
she's not going to pine for this guy
she's not going to have enthusiastic
monkey sex with him
unlikely agree with everything
explain nothing then do what's best for
you
how how is that good for a long-term
relationship between two people
you know when she's supposed to be a
compliment to his life and they're
supposed to be building something
together or if they're having a family
they want to have kids
overall guys i'm going to tell you this
if you see this book on a woman's
bookshelf
you better give it some time to vet her
properly to make sure that she's not
been brainwashed by this
crap agree with everything explain
nothing then do what's best for you
hey look you want to sign up for that
have fun with it
have fun with it make sure you get your
horse plow set up so you can plow the
fields for it because you will end up
becoming her plow horse
if you tell him you're not interested in
jumping into a relationship with both
feet he will set out to try to change
your mind
no he won't not guys that i talk to they
won't
they're not going to chase you dude
they're not going to chase you ladies
they're not
they got other things going on in their
lives like top show
see the the swiping habits of men and
women have been analyzed off of dating
apps and women that are
that would be rated somewhere between a
three and a ten
only swipe right on men that are rated
eight to ten
so what that means is there are way more
women
in the sexual marketplace interested in
those top shelf men
do you think for a minute ladies that he
is going to run around
chasing you trying to change his mind
because you say something silly like
i'm not interested in jumping into a
relationship with both feet you're going
to become friends with benefit or you're
going to become a plate
i mean the the concept of the book is
better relationships or
finding a husband you ain't gonna find
it acting like that
uh he must feel that you choose to be
with him not that you need to be with
him only then will he perceive you as a
equal partner
okay i'm gonna set aside only then will
he perceive you as an
equal partner for just a moment the
first part is correct
okay you want to choose women that
choose you
guys it's mostly guys you know watching
this and the same thing women i mean
like
ladies choose a man that chooses you
also right but
the last part to this is only then will
he perceive you as an equal partner
there's no equality in relationships
that's
a toxic feminist lie that's embedded
here in the book
okay standard narrative that we've seen
pop up over and over again
men and women are not equal they're a
compliment to one another
if you allow it to become a compliment
the problem is
society's taken that narrative and
flipped it upside down
and it doesn't exist that way anymore
and
you know i just had a coaching call
earlier this afternoon a few hours ago
dude was making about as much money as
his wife
but guess when his wife pulled out the
rug from underneath him
when she started making more money than
him
women see a test of woman's loyalty
is when men are unsuccessful a test of a
man's loyalty is when the man is
successful
so they're not looking for equality they
want to look up to a man they want to be
with a giant they want to
you know have access to all of that
stuff but anyway i'm almost done here
guys
um in the private chat just leave me a
quick message and let me know what it is
when you talk about guys so i can pull
you in and uh just organize it
uh every man wants to have sex first
whether he wants a girlfriend is
something he thinks about later by not
giving him what he wants up front
you become his girlfriend without him
realizing it
nope plugged in beta males might believe
that
but the top shelf men the alphas that
she's pining for
and last one here is a note i have
that she put in the book that says sass
is sexy
when guys talk to one another they often
tease and make fun of each other you're
going to see where this is leading in a
second
being able to banter and give a little
sass
show back shows sorry give a little sass
back shows him you can hold your own
and won't take crap from him not only
will it make you seem more
self-confident
but it will show him that you can stand
on your own two feet
men want to date feminine beauties they
don't want to date [ __ ]
okay we don't want to deal with sass
we don't want to deal with a hard life
coming home
with sass men men chop like bust each
other's chops because that's what we do
one of the red flags i put in my book in
fact and by the way you can get that
chapter for free you don't even have to
buy the book
i'll drop it there on the ticker but one
of the red flags
you'll just get on my email list that's
all and i don't spam guys i'll
only send out stuff you know if it's
important
one of the red flags is if she competes
with you which
ties into her busting your chops a woman
that competes with a man does not
see him as her best sexual option as her
best hypergamous option
she only competes with a man if she
doesn't see him that way
and is [ __ ] testing it's a competency
test so if a woman
is getting all sassy with you and trying
to bust your chops and
behaving like a man hey dudes sign up
for it if you want
but i can tell you you're not going to
have as good an experience as a guy
that gets involved with a feminine
beauty nobody wants
sass
you